hey what's up y'all I'm Tay Diggs and
I'm here at BuzzFeed to read thirst
tweets
I'm excited also a little bit scared
okay here we go
are you guys ready Taye Diggs still
makes my bussy sing first soprano I
don't know what a bus he is but this
doesn't sound so negative so great
wherever you are bus II keep singing
make sure you support and use your
diaphragm if you're singing for soprano
and I take an acting class with Taye
Diggs like oh my god
lick me oh my god lick me dry moving on
also being lucky enough to have a life
where I get to smell Taye Diggs
priceless that's cute this is from
Shonda Rhimes I'm gonna keep this sure I
need a job remind her get that Grey's
Anatomy money shoot do you think Taye
Diggs would let me bite him and walk
away or with the pesky police get
involved somehow I'd let you bite me how
about that I'm hoping you don't have
rabies and ted's could spread me into
cracker listen these people we don't
mess around I did not expect to be
embarrassed okay
Tadeusz could spread me on a cracker
licked me like an ice cream spoon me
like a bowl of soup then climb me like a
tree whoa just upon creativity alone I
want to meet this person you know I
should have read these first I'd let
Taye Diggs do things to me that I have
never let any boy do like read me poetry
in public or tell my parents about our
sex life
so there's reading poetry and then
there's telling her parents of us and
it's on the same oh my god I would never
talk to my parents about my sex life ah
people are so interesting aren't they my
dream is to have sugar daddy that looks
like Taye Diggs all right that's the
most sane one thus far so
kudos to you sugar daddy tight eggs
here's another one that just starts with
probably gonna have one of those Taye
Diggs sex dreams can we I want to do
this again I want to do this every week
I'm imagining how these people must
sound probably gonna have one of those
Taye Diggs sex dreams again tonight
probably will you keep dreaming probably
gonna have one again tonight shoot Taye
Diggs keep creeping into my sex dreams
I'm a platter though don't think I'm
having fun not making fun I'm very
appreciative been wanting to bite been
wanting to bite Taye Diggs but since my
days as a theater geek when he was in
rent I mean yes well done hey yo that
was awesome
thank you all for the support please
keep him coming because that was the
most fun I've had in a while
it's a it's exposure to a certain
caliber a fan that I'm very much into it
so bring it on thank you very much be
sure to watch all American on the CW we
got a great second season for you so so
tune in please bring me back again cuz
this was
[Music]
[Music]